my name is Beck's Hema I'm the Associate
Director of graduate programs at the
Stanford center for professional
development and I'm here with Marco
Pavoni
Jeannette bog and Dorsett Siddiq who
have who will be leading a two course
sequence in robotic autonomy that they
just recently redesigned and redeveloped
and so we're here to find out about
their research robotics and their course
great we'll start off with just each of
you introducing yourself so Marco could
you introduce yourself touching on your
research
sure I'm a faculty in the Department of
aeronautics and Astronautics where I
direct the autonomous systems laboratory
and I'm co-director for the Center for
Automotive Research at Stanford and I'm
also affiliated with the human centered
AI Institute my work is on decision
making and AI algorithms for robot
autonomy with application to Serfdom in
cars and autonomous aerospace vehicles
perfect Jeanette thank you
so my name is Jeanette bull I'm
assistant professor at the computer
science department for robotics and I'm
directing the interactive perception and
robot learning lab in the CS department
I'm also affiliated with the
human-centered AI Institute as all three
of us and my research is at the
intersection of robotics machine
learning and computer vision and all the
algorithms have been developing in the
course of my years of research are
applied to the problem of vision based
or sensor based robotic manipulation and
grasping thank you so I'm door sephadec
I'm an assistant professor in the
computer science and electrical
engineering department here at Stanford
I'm also the co-director of the eye
Safety Center and I'm also affiliated
with high human-centered AI so my
research is at the intersection of
robotics and human robot interaction
thinking about design of algorithms for
autonomous systems it's safely and
reliable you can interact with people
perfect and dorsa is a follow up I know
you have sort of an interesting path to
the research that you're currently doing
can you tell us a little bit about that
sure of course so at the beginning of my
PhD you and I started thinking about
what to do I was looking at
robotics and formal methods so I really
wanted to work at the intersection of
these two fields where formal methods is
this field where you're looking at
giving correctness guarantees for
autonomous systems and the goal of my
PhD thesis was to give guarantees for
autonomous cars the autonomous cars are
becoming a thing at that time and I
really wanted to be able to give
probably correct guarantees for these
systems and soon I realized one of the
biggest problems with autonomous cars
when you're trying to give guarantees
about them is just dealing with humans
there are all these human driven cars
around us and if you don't have good
models of them or if you have made-up
models of them then we can give some
sort of guarantees but it's important
what sort of models you're picking and
how we are deciding like what are the
humans around us are doing so so I do
think this area of human robot
interaction is really interesting and
that's how I got into it and how I
started thinking about interaction and
the fact that autonomous systems robots
are coming into our everyday lives and
we need to think about that interaction
and and the fact that there are humans
around us and we should model them in a
way that's useful for our autonomous
systems and robots fantastic so you've
touched on there one of the big
challenges for roboticists today can you
what are some of the other challenges
for yeah so I think it's a very good
time for robotics I think there are a
lot of interesting opportunities and
interesting challenges in robotics so
one of the biggest ones is I think
dealing with humans and dealing with
uncertain environments I think in
addition to that we have few other
challenges things like generalizability
and how we can think about like
combining model-based and data-driven
techniques and how we should go about
that for solving really difficult
robotics problems and then going back to
uncertainty I think another difficult
problem is thinking about giving
guarantees and safety and how we can
find like under uncertainty and how we
can give probably correct guarantees and
think it going back to the safety
problem how can how can we give
guarantees for our autonomous systems
mark oh I know you also work a lot on
decision making under in uncertain
environments can you elaborate on that
challenge yes absolutely
robot autonomy reading tales designing
robotic systems that need to operate in
situations that you know before see
cannot be foreseen at the design stage
and those situations require reasoning
so the challenge is how do we provide
the
currencies and the guarantees for robots
that need to respond to situations that
cannot be foreseen at the design stage
so good portion of my work is devoted to
techniques that allow roubles to
generalize the behaviors to situations
that cannot be anticipated at the design
stage and in a way for so that we can
have a trust in an confidence in what
the robot does and unite your work works
you also focus both on through this
problem general generalizability as well
as some of the challenges that dorsa
touch down on the models that we use
could you develop that right yeah so
maybe also just to expand on what
Michael just said the problem of having
a robot act in an uncertain environment
it's also something that I'm very
interested in it's a very hard problem
and is typically engineered away in
environments like car manufacturing
factories for example where the
environment is designed in such a way
that robot doesn't have to deal with an
uncertainty at all and can just execute
pre-programmed
motions but if we aim for having the
robot actually help us in our house at
home with annoying tasks that nobody
wants to do or in dangerous environments
that we don't want people to actually be
in a robot will experience all these
unstructured environments and it only
has sensors that that basically give it
access to partial information on me and
still it needs to be able to make safe
decisions on how to act in this
environment and also for bass phones and
even if it makes a failure it should be
able to recover from this failure and we
do and these are all challenges that we
don't know really how to do today and
it's very exciting to work on those yeah
so sort of building on what what you
said or if marco door so if you want to
chime in but you've talked about in the
past also the challenges of collecting
data that it's very expensive and can be
dangerous to collect data with robots
can you build on that or if anybody
wants to
right so I can maybe start talking about
this so there is a huge opportunity
right now in robotics to actually use
machine learning based methods to enable
robots to do tasks that were previously
not possible because maybe we cannot
have good models like for example in the
human case or also in terms of physics
based models or for example fluids or
deformable objects and learning based
methods allow us to maybe learn models
instead of having to hand design doors
for these difficult physical processes
for example but current machine learning
approaches rely heavily on large amounts
of data and in other applications that
computer vision or natural language
processing this kind of data is
relatively easy to collect and to label
but in robotics what it means to collect
data is typically to have an actual
physical machine interact with the
environment in such a way that it
doesn't destroy itself or is a danger to
any anyone around it or breaks anything
in the environment and also takes just
longer for a robot to execute a motion
rather than just looking at a picture
and labeling it and therefore it's
actually much more a much bigger effort
for a robot to collect that kind of data
that is required for current machine
learning techniques so I think there's a
huge opportunity in robotics to use
machine learning but it also poses a
challenge to actually that is very
specific to robotics where it's hard to
collect enough data for current
algorithms and I think you know just to
add on what Janelle was talking about I
think another opportunity here is like
we've seen all these advances of deep
learning and natural language processing
and vision and one of one of the reasons
is data
but another interesting thing is we've
been using model-based approaches for
robotics for many years and these
model-based techniques can provide
really good priors really good like
inductive biases and actually help us
improve like a lot of deep learning type
techniques that we have so it actually
helps us improve machine learning - like
having this new problem that we have in
addition to having like extra data I
think there's a lot of interesting
directions that one can take thinking
about data driven and
and how they should how we should
combine them to solve some of these
really difficult problems in robotics
yeah and if you think about it's
interesting how in the AI community
oftentimes people consider the abundance
of data as a challenge euro bollocks we
have the different challenge
it's a scarcity of data which as doors
Anjanette were saying opens up an
opportunity in order to devise
techniques that are really tailored to
robotics and clear to creatively combine
model based produce with the model free
approaches and carefully design ways of
collecting data and so on and so forth
fantastic what are some of the other
opportunities that you see for
roboticists today marco in terms of
research or in terms of applications
both terms of research so we talked
about the generalizability we talked
about how to interact with humans in a
seamless way I would like to reiterate
the challenge that an opportunity that
Jeanette mentioned which is the one of
interacting with environment usually for
robotic systems as long as they do not
touch something yeah you can still do it
but the moment they started touching
manipulating a certain environment then
it becomes really a gray area with a lot
of open questions and then the aspect of
safety not safety is a difficult concept
and in the context of robotics first of
all different applications demand
different levels of acidity of course
safety for self-driving cars is
different than safety for a warehouse
robots and second of all it's a concept
that needs to be trade triggered off
with the efficiency meaning that as
humans we constantly make good judgment
calls in how to properly trade the
safely with efficiency it's really easy
for a self-driving car to be safe just
as a move or it
relatively easy for self-driving car to
be very efficient it always go at
maximum speed but sometimes sometimes it
might collide the question is how do you
trade the tool in such a way to find a
sweet spot now finding techniques to
achieve that trade is still very much an
open challenge do I so could you build
on that because I know you've done
research both on that sort of trade-off
of efficiency and safety as well as the
interaction with humans right because
robots can start influencing humans as
well yeah so I think the influencing
humans is also another interesting
aspect of it it goes back to like
interacting with the environment - right
once we are touching the environment
you're changing the environment once
you're interacting with the person
you're changing the person you're
influencing the person and thinking
about how our actions as an autonomous
car or as a robot is going to influence
humans and how our human is going to
respond and how their models change is
actually really interesting and
challenging and just to build up on what
marco was just talking about so so we
have all these different challenges
which is really interesting and and
you're doing research on them and it's
exciting because you're teaching a class
that's trying to like cover all these
topics that aren't these new exciting
topics and robotics but I think there
are a lot of interesting opportunities
in industry too so I think these are
like academic like from an academic
perspective these are challenges and
problems that we can go about solving
and learning about but from an industry
perspective we've seen robotic systems
like in factory floors like maybe
working in factory floors and doing
awesome things but we haven't really
seen them like coming into our everyday
lives yet
right like autonomous cars it's kind of
a step in that direction but within
general I think there's a lot of
interesting opportunities from an
industrial perspective from an
application perspective thinking about
robots coming into our everyday like
life thinking about helper robots or
companion robots or robots helping in
like hospitals or in homes like
especially if it are like elderly
population increasing I think it's a
it's an interesting opportunity to look
at there are other applications like
agriculture or like space like as Marko
works on that we can think about how
robots can help us and actually coming
into coming more coming into our
everyday lives in a more like
tangible way yeah and this a very good
point and in fact one of the key
motivation for us for us to develop this
core series is to in a way democratize
the tools behind the robot autonomy in
hope that we can spare a new set of
ideas from industry new set of
applications that as of now we are not
even aware of I think that might be a
good transition I want to come back to
some of the things we've talked about
but maybe to discuss the classes
themselves so Jeannette what is what is
one of the things that you're most
excited to teach in this course right so
stores are already said we're actually
touching on four areas within the course
which is learning based method for
robotics systems integration and
verification and validation we're
looking at physical interaction for
manipulation and grasping of mobile
robots and we're looking at interaction
with humans and on none of these topics
is really taught yet at least at
Stanford in this integrated way on an
actual platform and so first amount of
all I'm excited about this kind of cut
through all of these areas because
typically in robotics people are very
focused and almost a bit siloed in their
particular areas so they are perception
experts control experts motion planning
experts human robot interaction expert
and they typically don't know the field
of the other these other fields very
well but robotic a robot is actual a
physical system in which all of these
things have to come together and if you
put modules together that are developed
in an isolated manner they may not
actually work that well together if you
put them into a system justice is so
this course actually provides this
opportunity to put all of these
different kind of components of a system
together and actually see what happens
and what is required on a systems level
as well so that's something I'm very
excited about actually yeah so the idea
is that of course people will become
experts in a particular domain of course
this is you making
or perception about information and so
on but we're taking these courses they
will also develop enough breadth of
expertise so that they will be able to
read them in a principled way about the
interfaces between what we do and the
other capabilities in the autonomous
text so that I can place proper
assumptions they can consider
interruptions among the different
modules of the term is that they have
the potential to really work in practice
so Marco this originally was just a 1/4
sequence that you got and now it's
expanding to quarters and you're working
all three of you together yes can you
explain so I think you've already
touched on it but what was the impetus
behind expanding it into a larger course
and bringing in additional instructors
well the impetus behind was a very much
aligned we watched a net set that as
part of a medication realized that I had
a pretty good good grasp about
techniques in decision-making and
controls but I did not have enough
exposure in my opinion to other fields
of robotics so one of the main
motivations behind design in this class
was to give students the opportunity to
have exposure to the different modules
of the autonomy stack and how they
integrate and how to talk to each other
so I started teaching this class three
years ago with the goal of teaching the
foundations of robot autonomy so the
most basic capabilities to make a robot
really autonomous capabilities such as a
trajectory optimization decision-making
visual based perception localization and
mapping of the mathematics behind the
algorithms how to code these algorithms
in the robot operating system and how to
deploy the autonomy stack that the
students incrementally build throughout
the course on a physical machine and in
an effort
teach students how to think at the
system level and this response from the
students has been enthusiastic which
prompted me together with the doors Amma
Jeannette to think about an advanced
version of this class where we go beyond
the basic capabilities and actually we
consider we teach state of the art
capabilities that in the end the really
the ones that are opening up all the new
exciting applications that were
discussed before the new exciting
capabilities as a ready mention include
learning based methods in particular
with the perspective allowing a robot to
generalize to new scenarios that have
not been seen prior to that experience
verification and validation in order to
teach students how to reason about
safety for a system that has reasoning
capabilities and then interaction with
environment interaction with humans we
believe that through these two classes
series the students will be equipped
with a set of tools that we have no time
to really think about new research
challenges on the one hand but also new
application opportunities on the other
hand dresser so building on our markers
last comment what what would you hope
that students take away from this class
the two core sequence or the second
course yes I think one interesting thing
that we get out of this robotic series
course and I think I really want the
students to get out of it is to kind of
understand that if you want to build a
really like full like robotic system you
need to you should not be scared of like
touching the physical robot you should
actually coat its understanding that you
need all these different fields to come
together to solve to solve a really
challenging robotics problem and I think
like a lot of these boundaries that we
put in between departments are very
superficial boundaries right like
robotics is kind of like a true
interdisciplinary field and this class
is also cross-listed between computer
science or electrical engineering so I
think it's it's very it's very
substantial it's very actually I don't
know what's say here so I think it's
very useful for this
to kind of be able to use a physical
system and code it up and actually like
deal with real sensors and understand
what are the real challenges that you
would have in robotic system yeah maybe
I can build up on on top of this is love
what you said so the thing that I really
love about robotics is that it is
interdisciplinary so you can come in
with almost any kind of knowledge any
kind of background knowledge you have
and contribute to the field it's
something I really love about it and I
hope that in this course this is
reflected by actually touching upon all
these different areas she do you hope it
also appeals to a broad range of
students that you're not just pulling in
arrow and Astronautics or just CS you're
hoping not only that but I think that it
will be instrumental to the success of
this class for example for the
deployment of the software on the
physical platform we divide students in
groups and we make an effort to make
sure that within each group there are
people with a different background
really to reflect this idea of a need
for system thinking interdisciplinary
thinking when it comes to robot autonomy
so robotics is a team sport
yeah what do you think will be Jeanette
what do you think will be the most
surprising thing that students will take
away from the course mmm-maybe how hard
it is you know they if you have never
worked with a robot before the things
you are consciously aware of our movies
like Hollywood movies or also YouTube
videos from awesome companies like for
example Boston Dynamics right where they
show these capabilities or you see
research results that of course somewhat
biased towards the positive outcomes but
everyone who has worked with the real
robot knows that for making a robot work
once there have been weeks and weeks of
development and failure behind it and I
think that is something that you can
take away if you get work of your real
physical robot platform so they mean
yeah and I completely agree we watch and
it's just
to the point that actually in the class
we put a lot of emphasis on teaching
also software engineering principles and
specifically for robotics on the one
hand to teach students how to if
possible minimize the effort but at the
same time how to be able to isolate
failures and quickly address those in an
effort to incremental improve the
performance of the robot so they won't
leave the class with a fully functioning
walking dog that moves around maybe
coming back to the research Jenna you've
I know you're you've talked about this
problem of generalizability and you work
on integrating multiple sensors in a row
in a robot can you maybe elaborate on
that
yeah I wanted to mention this already
when we talked about opportunities
because something that is very special
for robot as compared to maybe methods
in computer vision or natural language
processing instead of robot is a
physical system that has many sensors so
it doesn't just have a camera or only a
microphone it also has skin it has
sensing in all the joints so that robot
actually knows where all his limbs are
and it makes physical contact with the
environment that in turn change the
sensory input to all of these sensors
right so if it physically interacts
there might be a sound or there might be
motion in the camera or there might be
feedback on the tactile sensors and
there's an opportunity here to exploit
all of these different sensors that are
currently excited in a way but at the
same time it's a challenge to actually
integrate all of these different sensors
because they have a very different
structure and dimensionality and frame
rate and all these things and it's not
clear how to really do that well but
it's one of the core question that I'm
asking in my research together with my
students so this is both an opportunity
and a challenge exactly it makes things
easier
because there's more information richer
information at the same time
algorithmically it's harder because it's
unclear how to fuse this information how
to really exploit it yeah yeah I guess
the same thing kind of happens and
you're dealing with humans right when
you have humans interacting with robots
there's this new setting where you have
interesting interactions going on
between very complex agents that are
decision-makers or thinking about what
they're doing and it's interesting to be
able to like extract kind of lower
dimensional embeddings of what is this
interaction that's happening between the
humans or between the robots and whoever
it is lower dimensional representation
is a salic intent or goal and use that
for the robot to plan better or to plan
to positively influence humans or to
work better and collaborate with humans
great so you're going to be teaching you
know the next the next crop of
roboticists so dorsa what do you think
you you were research on human human
interaction with robots what do you
think the next 50 years will hold for
that yeah so so it's an exciting area
and I hope that in the next like 15 to
20 years you would be able to have
robots seamlessly and easily collaborate
to people I really want a robot to come
and try to like do a task like cook like
a meal with a person like I would really
want to see that in the next like 20
years having a robot in our homes in our
kitchen being able to figure out like
can I start like chopping the onions no
what is the next thing to do and just
come in and help me like in real time
and there are a lot of real robotics
challenges there too it's not just the
human interaction just real-time
planning for robots is is really hard
but there are also these challenges of
like figuring out like what the intent
of the person is predicting what the
person is doing and and easily coming to
people's spaces and collaborate with
them either through like touch or just
just through motion and interaction with
the person so ideally I would want to
have robots and homes helping people
sojanet and building on that I know
you've talked about one of the
challenges of for instance a robot
working in the kitchen is its which I
didn't know it's hard to model how to
grab a soft food or how to deal with
rubble can you build on that as maybe
and maybe where you see the kind of
research you're doing going in the next
50 years so it's very high to predict
what's going to happen
but what dorset example the toilet doors
have just made is actually a very
interesting one for me as well my core
expertise is not in human robot
interaction but my core expertise is in
the perception capabilities using all
these different sensors for example
which clearly are required to also make
that scenario work so it's a nice an
area to actually think about also these
core challenges I'm looking at so it's
also very exciting scenario for me I
also think that robots are definitely I
mean right now they're really bad you
put the car factory right where
everything is nicely controlled but
they're really not very good unless you
control the environment and you let them
do a very specific test so I'm really
hoping that at some point they can do
these kinds of tasks and I think it will
be much easier to have a setup where you
have some kind of shared autonomy or a
collaborative system because it's much
harder to aim for full autonomy I think
this human robot interaction really
gives an opportunity to speed up this
development because yeah robot could
actually help a person to ask a question
or ask it to actually show it how to do
something by guiding that yeah I mean
it's a robotics for pi what is difficult
for a human it can be very easy for a
robot and what is easy for a human is
extremely different you know robot are
extremely good at extremely precisely
positioning something with millimeter
accuracy when you ask a robot to track
an onion so one of my hopes is that in
the next 20 years we are going to change
little bit is a say in robotics in order
to allow a new generation of robots I
can really work for example alongside
humans in order to relieve some of the
most dangerous or annoying tasks in
addition
given also my aerospace background
currently there is a lot of hope and
that robot autonomy would allow to
accomplish tasks in space either in
orbit or on other planets or planetary
bodies that currently cannot be
accomplished through deliberation the
big challenge though is that because of
all the reasons that I should not
mention in particular that robots are
bad often an open environment there is
very little trust about these
technologies to the point that people
prefer not to consider missions because
there is an unacceptable level of risk
that the robot might fail well I hope
again that in the next 20 years
this will change and it will open up new
opportunities to accomplish missions in
orbit for example repairing a satellite
with a satellite mechanic something and
also explore new environments for
example and now we know that there are a
number of planetary bodies with an ocean
within so I think would be a dream for
myself for the robotic community to be
able to go to those places and visit
those oceans and possibly look for forms
of life anything you want to add to kind
of the future the next 50 years maybe
was too ambitious but the next five to
ten years what you see on the horizon
for robotics Genet yeah even in
relatively hard to predict so I mean
there's this big questions about the
question about autonomous driving right
and if we will see autonomous cars and
in your future I'm very skeptical about
this within actually the next 5-10 years
but maybe you can I don't know what your
opinion actually is but I'm one and even
if you don't want to go so full autonomy
deep
having a shared autonomy system was a
person who maybe has to take over it's
very challenging to do that so I don't
even quite know in that field how it's
gonna go
in terms of manipulation which is kind
of what I'm mainly working on I think
there are probably more interesting
useful solutions when it comes to
warehouse robotics this seems more in
reach when robots have to actually deal
with an absolutely huge amount of
different objects that come in every day
to warehouse and have to be packaged so
I think we made really good progress in
the last 10 years in that and research
on just picking placed us in these
environments has moved now more and more
to industry as well
so I think this could be something to
consider in the next five to ten years
that it's actually going to happen this
is more automated robotics goes in waves
and there are ears which there are very
high expectations and then we go into
the winter of robotics and so on I
usually joke by saying that in the 1560s
people were considering a general AI
troubles that could do everything in our
houses and some 50 years later the
robotics community has delivered a
Roomba which is a great problem but it
is very far from an assistive robot I
can do anything but I think that there
is a difference with respect to the
different ways weights first of all now
we have massive investments in in this
field second of all I think we have
brand new tools that allow us to tackle
problems that previously were very
difficult to be tackled and three there
are a number of focused applications
like warehouse
robotics or drones for Army cultures and
so on which are maybe a little bit less
ambitious then say general AI for a
robot assistant but still extremely
useful from
it's a Saeta standpoint and much more
achievable from a technological
standpoint so I would say it's difficult
to predict what will happen the next 10
to 20 years but I released I will say
that this excitement about robotics
would stay and we I don't see a winter
body we're still in the summer of
robotics yes that so I do agree that
like if you look at AI like at the
beginning you really wanted to go with
this intelligence that's gonna solve
like everything and it's going to be
close to like humans intelligence and
everything is gonna be great and and
that was just - too much of like big
goal that was impossible and then we saw
the winter of AI and then later I think
what happened was there was a shift of
like paradigms right like people started
thinking about okay I don't really want
to have this intelligence the super
intelligence that works as well as
humans I just want to build the system
that's useful I can like do displaying
that that I really wanted to do like
drive or or do this thing and like
warehouse settings and I think the same
thing is about robotics as long as we
build systems that are going to like
help people and be useful I think that
is that is pretty like that's pretty
like good the other point that I wanted
to make about driving is you're the
technology for driving I think you've
made a lot of advances there and it's
it's very close to like being there
right but there are a lot of other
factors that come in when you think
about deploying these systems to like
our real like roads and and I think
those are also other challenges as one
might want to think about like legal
challenges or against safety challenges
like how to ensure the cars what happens
in the case of accidents so I think
those are also some of the challenges
that are really real when you think
about deploying the robotic system into
the real world just building on that can
you talk maybe doesn't have to be
predictive next five to ten years but
how will robots change the way we act so
if we're if robots come into the kitchen
or on the car on the roads how will that
change the way humans act yes so I have
a story from myself I used to live in
San Francisco until like a month ago and
there you see all these autonomous cars
testing and really difficult it's like
situations because the city is is quite
challenging and what happens a lot of
times these car gets stuck at
intersections so I see
getting stuck at intersections a lot and
what happens now is when I see them I
just go around them and and it's kind of
crazy that based on that like three
interactions that I've had with an
autonomous car I've decided to change my
behavior and go around it so it is it is
interesting to look into how like humans
adapt to these to these autonomous
systems as we are putting in and some of
it is not predictable it's actually
really hard to predict what happens if I
put in like ten autonomous cars on the
road how is that going to affect traffic
like how is that going to affect some of
the larger objectives and global
objectives that you care about as a
society so I think that's that's an
interesting active area of research and
and it's hard to predict right now like
how what happens if I put in a hopper
robot in in homes and what is the
long-term effect of that and the
short-term effects you are doing some
works on that so thinking about the
short-term like interactions and how
that is going to affect people but
repeated long-term interaction and
effects of that is is really interesting
to study
and we're back and we have a new guest
so can you introduce this robot you want
to use it sure this is a platform that
we use throughout this course series and
this platform has a set of
representative sensors that you may find
for example on a self-driving car for
example another sensor camera for the
very capable processors and also a
gripper in order to test the algorithms
that we'll be covering in this class
about the manipulations and how it
always should interact with the
environment
now the s part of the class we also
provide a simulator whereby before
deploying
the autonomous tech on the platform we
actually run the tests on a simulator
that quite closely emulates the
capability of the robot unfortunately
for the first year of this class the
platform won't be available to remote
students but those of you that are lata
will be welcome to come to our teaching
lab and actually work with the physical
platform itself can you talk so what
what are the kinds of tasks that you
will be asking people the robots to
perform were people that had to make the
robots perform right so maybe in the
first in the first word theater
so for in the first course so robot
autonomy one the main test of the robot
will be navigation basic in a maze right
and I can a kind of fake city
essentially and we'll have a heavily
rely on this really interesting sensor
that actually if you're studying
computer science or any of the other
engineering degrees you suddenly I think
have the opportunity to actually work
with that kind of data I have myself
I've actually never worked with that
kind of sensor so I'm also excited about
that and then
so that will be about navigation and
then in the second edition of the course
Oh robot autonomy - we will also amongst
others look at grasping manipulation
capabilities where we basically want the
students to be able to pick up
particular specific objects and maybe
bring them to specific places so
combining manipulation capabilities with
navigation capabilities and of course
they will need to use visual sensing to
actually find these kinds of objects and
maybe react appropriately when the
object slips out of the scraper or and
things like that so that would be very
interesting so all of the sudden these
very simple tasks become a task of
perceiving neural environment localizing
there are about within the environment
reasoning about environment classifying
objects for what they really are and
then scheduling a series of tasks to
accomplish a goal so it is to say how
robotics is a challenging field because
even easy things like moving objects
around entail a number of a fairly
complex capabilities that we as humans
take for granted but that actually
require a lot of mathematical
understanding of the problem and a lot
of software engineering skills in order
to realize those that Mathematica
understanding into something that
actually works
another interesting that we are thinking
about adding towards the end of the
class the sections are at interaction
with the with the physical world and
interaction with people is having
multiple of them trying to do a
collaborative task together so if you
have a block and we bring in like two of
them together how would they work
together to move an object if one of
them is let's say totally operated and
the other ones autonomous thinking about
challenges they're interesting fantastic
anything else you want to add about does
it have a name each one will have a 28
of them oh and they each have a name yes
do you know this one is Astro so until
last year they were named after food
girl recipes like
there was the chopper and a whopper I
didn't know there were so many different
types but now that we are we have a 28
platforms we couldn't find the 28
minutes of burgers so now we have a
different menu scale okay